the school's minister nick gibb is with
us now hello to you minister what do you
think about a new sir she's
very you like it very nice indeed smells
lovely as well
nice and shiny and new i'm guessing
that's what schools are going to be like
as well today for the first time yes
and i was visiting some schools in uh in
leicester 10 days ago and they did smell
of cleaning fluid
a huge amount of effort has been gone
into by head teachers and staff up and
down the country making sure that our
schools are safe
there are bubbles there are in the
school i went to there was a year seven
zone year eight zone all color coded
staggered lunch and playtime breaks
uh hand sanitizers in classrooms more
hand basins
different entrances to the school a huge
amount of effort
to make sure that schools are safe for
young people and should it be schools
that are paying for that though as
opposed to the government
well we had a scheme before the summer
where schools could claim back up to 75
000 pounds
for extra costs depending on the size of
the school clearly cost whether
suspected case of covert and so on
we've just started the first year of a
very uh quite a good
spending settlement for schools over the
next three years fourteen and a half i'm
just looking at 216 million is how much
it's going to cost
schools for coveted cleaning are you
going to compensate them for that well
we always keep these issues under review
schools do have
as i said a very uh large increase in
spending this year and over the next two
years to cover these kind of costs
we've also allocated to schools a one
billion pound
a catch-up fund to help schools to help
their pupils catch up for any lost
education
so it's a matter of prioritizing where
do you want the extra funding to go and
we think catch-up is hugely important
for young people
so was that a yes or no to my class well
we keep it under review but as i said
there's
the funding settlement for schools this
year in the next two years that we
negotiated with the treasury
has been very generous uh and that's the
funding that's for
these kind of extra incentives we keep
it under review
okay um what percentage of kids going
back to school today would you be happy
with
because as we know a lot of parents are
still very worried about their children
going back to school well
the what the chief medical officers are
saying of all four nations is actually
it's better now for children to be in
school the risk of
contracting catching the virus in the
school environment is
is very low but the risk of not being in
school actually can be quite damaging to
children's
uh mental health and also that long-term
prospect of education so the polling has
been showing
increasing confidence from parents over
the last few weeks
and the nht published a survey last week
showing that something like 97 of
schools would be open but you must have
a percentage rate that you'll be content
with you know
is it 75 is it 80 percent is it 100
well we want all children to be back in
schools
well we last week we had a very high
levels of attendance at schools in in
leicestershire they where they start
school early over the course of this
week we will see
uh as each the each day the new term
begins in different local authorities we
will see i'm confident
increasing numbers of parents sending
their children back to school helping
them to catch up
get on track with their education
because that does affect the life
chances of those young people what if
they don't
what's going to happen to parents if
they don't send their kids back well
school is mandatory uh in this country
we believe in compulsory education
uh so all the all the rules about
attendance will apply
from today in in in schools there'll be
some leeway though
well you're not going to find people
talking away fines have always been the
last resort
for head teachers but it is a last
resort uh tool that they have to make
sure that young people are attending
school
of course there will be some parents who
are concerned and
what i would say to those families is to
talk to the head teacher
so that he can he or she can assure them
that you know
the measures are in place to keep
schools safe but they you know
any concerns that people have they
should raise for school
parents watching this morning thinking
about sending the kids to school
thinking about not sending the kids to
school
what is going to happen if their kids
don't go to school today they'll get a
call from their head teacher
they'll get a warning what what's going
to happen well the head teachers and
schools they will be concerned about
people not attending they'll want to
understand
the reasons for any concern and the
heads will want to
you know assure families that actually
the measures that have been taken
to keep schools safe uh i'll have been
incredible
and i've seen it myself the efforts that
schools have gone to with the hand
sanitizers the extra
hand basically understand that the
cleanliness of the schools to keep it
absolutely risk to minimize any risk of
transmitting the right totally get that
but nevertheless there will still be
parents who are concerned
are we saying that they're going to get
a call from the school to start with and
if they continue to break the rules
then there will be a fine but some way
down the track well as i said it's
always a last resort the issue of fines
head teachers and staff will be
concerned if people are not attending
it's easy how will that concern manifest
itself well that's what well schools
will
have their own approaches to attendance
and they will be phony many schools will
be phoning up parents to make sure
uh that they uh that they are attending
i hear you know i've heard of
head teachers organizing a walking bus
to
you know to talk to families who are
concerned and to encourage them to
to come into school because it does
matter being in school what the chief
medical officers are saying is that the
risk of not attending school now
far outweigh the very small risk of the
of the virus being transmitted in the
school environment and they did look
also don't forget we've had 1.6 million
pupils
back in school last term leading up to
the summer when we brought back
reception year one and year six
yeah um so you know the schools are used
to being open they are used to putting
measures in place to keep young people
and the staff of course
uh safe from the transmission of the
virus how many cases will be too many in
a school and you'll have to close it
well we have now a test and trace
system that gives us granular
information about whether there has been
an increase
in the transmission of virus in
particular local areas and where we see
that
we will and we have take action taken
action to impose new restrictions in
those local areas
so so i think parents can be assured and
also we have the thing called the survey
testing where we
survey uh sample households across the
country to see
if there has been a risk of but if
there's a covey case in in a classroom
will you just close that classroom will
you close the whole school what will you
do
when there's a positive case of
coronavirus then the local uh public
health team will give advice to the
school and that will be about tracing
the contacts
of that people and then they will be
then asked to sell so they're not
necessarily closing the school
not necessarily it will depend on the
extent of the contacts that that pupil
has had whether there are other
positive cases of chronovirus but they
will take advice from the local health
protection scheme we may be
sending in mobile testing units into a
school there's a whole raft of
measures that we will take uh if there
are cases
of positive cases of chronovirus in the
school okay can i rattle through another
few questions for you i know you've got
a dash
um exam result exams rather going back
until july potentially of next year
apparently your boss the education
secretary is thinking about it tell us
more
well in mid-june uh he wrote to the
regulator asking
directing them to look into the
possibility of delaying the exams we
have to take into account the other
nations
of the uk northern ireland and wales
that use the gcse and a levels but this
is something
that we are looking at and have been
looking at for several weeks when will
you decide
i will decide as soon as we've as soon
as we have
talked spoken to other nations we would
take a decision we'll decide
as soon as we can okay so quite soon
within a few weeks well as soon as we
can
okay